First We Begin tonight our top story the
president's adult son Hunter might soon
be forced to move out of the White House
where he is now rumored to be living
into a federal prison
today attorney for Hunter Biden met with
poj officials to discuss the status of
several looming charges including at
least one felony tax violation and one
felony weapons charge now we know that
Hunter has been under investigation
since at least 2018 according to the
hills CBS The Washington Post Federal
investigators now believe they have
sufficient evidence to now charge Hunter
Biden our sources are saying that in
fact that may be imminent now this
reportedly involves dozens of what they
call SARS or suspicious activity reports
stemming from the large foreign
transactions and of course the nebulous
shell corporations and llc's seemingly
designed to hide the transfer of money
now also a huge delinquent tax bill
recently paid off by a Biden family
friend and there is also substantial
evidence that Hunter lied on a Firearms
application falsely claiming that he has
not been addicted to any substances in
2018 okay okay so given the mountain of
evidence here's a question we all need
to ask if the last name was Trump do you
think they would have acted faster or
would they go slow like this why has it
taken so long to charge Hunter Biden now
it apparently helps to have friends in
high places and both the Attorney
General of the U.S Merrick Garland and
the Secretary of State Tony blinken they
have been credibly accused now of
shielding hunter from any and all
accountability and also Protecting
President Joe Biden in the process
question we need to ask is what did Joe
Biden know when did he know it and did
Joe Biden personally benefit financially
from Hunter's Farm business dealings and
if he did is he a compromised president
is that room for impeachment a possible
impeachment let us be clear here this
gets serious nobody really cares if a
former crackhead and deadbeat dad and a
guy that sells paintings paint by number
paintings Hunter Biden goes to prison
this is about protecting the big guy
whose fine finances are very
suspiciously apparently co-mingled with
his son that's what they're looking into
now for years high-ranking government
officials have gone to Great Lengths to
protect the Shady Biden family Syndicate
now that was reportedly selling Federal
access to America's number one number
two geopolitical foes at the same time
the feds have twisted and contorted the
law in order to persecute another guy by
the name of Donald J Trump for example
the federal documents probe is totally
absurd according to a brand new Breaking
report tonight from John Solomon while
Trump's legal team now has issued a
letter to Congress accusing the doj of
misleading the courts and the American
people by disregarding President Trump's
ongoing cooperation with the National
Archives prior to the early morning raid
at Mar-A-Lago Trump's team is now asking
Congress to pass legislation to fix this
archaic and disorganize you know
procedures surrounding classified
documents but I imagine the weaponized
doj would simply prefer a prosecution
against Biden's top political opponent
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else